[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: On this
end of The Boardwalk,
I'm joined by former attorney,
human rights activist,
and inclusive
designer Elise Roy.
Elise, thanks for
coming to I/O Live.
ELISE ROY: Thanks
for having me here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: For those that
don't know your back story,
you lost your hearing at age 10.
ELISE ROY: I did.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Which is why we're
going to be using Google's
Live Transcribe app
to make our conversation
happen in real time.
Can you tell us what it means
to be an inclusive designer?
ELISE ROY: Absolutely.
So an inclusive
designer is someone
that helps organizations
solve problems
from the perspective of
people with disabilities,
or difference.
It's based on this
human-centered design tenet
that, when we
solve for extremes,
we often develop
better solutions
than when we solve for average.
And that might seem kind
of counter-intuitive,
because the greatest
number of people
tend to hover around average.
But the problem is that no
one actually is average,
and so when we
solve for average,
and people are a little
bit over here, a little bit
there, there's this gap
between what we create,
and what their needs are
that we're not meeting.
If instead, we solve
for those extremes,
then we've already
covered that gap,
and we've created
something that's
a lot more adaptable, and
a lot more innovative.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
makes so much sense to me,
and it reminds me of something
else that you've talked about,
which is human-centered design.
Can you define that
term for us, as well?
ELISE ROY: Sure.
So human-centered design is
a philosophy, a methodology,
for problem solving.
It's based on a lot
of things that we've
taken from the
design realm, and it
can be applied to almost
every realm you could imagine,
from international development,
to privacy, to the sciences,
to technology.
And what differentiates it,
is its almost obsessive focus
on designing around the human
that we're trying to reach.
So in the past, a
lot of times, we
think that when we're
trying to solve a problem,
we want to get all the
experts into this room,
and have them figure
out how to solve it.
The problem with
that is, they have
one point of view, their own.
So if, for example, they're
a bunch of developers,
they're probably going to create
something that's very complex,
and most of us don't-- you know,
the so-called average people,
don't really understand.
If instead we focus our
process on the people
we're trying to reach, then
we develop something that
fits their needs much better.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
ELISE ROY: And so there's a
lot of empathy involved, where
you're trying to understand
what their needs are,
you're following them around
in real-life situations.
You want to make
sure that you're also
answering the right problem.
So many people are
answering the wrong problem.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
ELISE ROY: And then
there's ideation,
which is similar
to brainstorming,
but we use a lot
of design methods
to really get people
thinking outside the box.
It's a lot more powerful.
We want people to
throw out crazy ideas,
we want as many as
they can think of.
And then, we prototype,
which is a lo-fi solution
that we know we're going
to mess up with, you know?
But that's the purpose of it,
is to fail and to learn from it.
And then the last step is to
implement it, and make sure
that it's sustainable.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I love this
idea of having practices
and mechanisms for
helping experts get out
of their perspective.
Because when you bring
an expert in the room,
you're asking them to give
their expert opinion, not
their general opinion.
And that's so focused
most of the time, right?
ELISE ROY: Exactly, exactly.
And that's also why I
love inclusive design,
because that brings people even
further outside of their tunnel
vision.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes, I see.
This reminds me of another
quote of yours, if I may.
You said, "when we look
for gaps of exclusion,
we identify opportunities
for great change."
And I find this
really inspiring.
Do you have some examples
that you can share,
where you see this
really clearly?
ELISE ROY: Definitely.
I can give you some
Google-centric examples.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
ELISE ROY: So Google's Chief
Internet Evangelist, Vint Cerf,
he created email
for his deaf wife.
And as you know, that's become a
huge thing that everyone loves.
But he didn't see
it as something
that would be applied
to everyone, initially.
And most people didn't think
of it in that way at first,
because we have the capabilities
to talk to people on phone,
and that was the way
that business was run.
But slowly, we realized that
people also have this desire
to not have to keep talking
to someone on the phone,
and they want to say
something real quick,
and be done with it.
And sometimes, we
also have this desire
to formulate our thoughts before
we communicate with someone.
And email filled
those hidden desires.
Another example is YouTube.
They inserted closed captioning
capabilities into their media
player, which was really
amazing at the time,
and closed captioning
was originally
created for the deaf, so
that they could follow along.
But what YouTube realized was
that if a video has closed
captioning capabilities,
then the likelihood
of it being watched to the
end was increased by 80%.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Wow.
ELISE ROY: Yes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Is that because
there's so many situations
where you have to sound off?
ELISE ROY: Exactly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
ELISE ROY: So the reason why
designing for inclusion works
is because we find ourselves,
as we go about our lives,
in these momentary
situations where
we have a momentary disability.
So we might be
carrying something,
and we lose the use of our arms.
If we're in a bar,
closed captioning
is helpful, because
we can't hear.
And if we are in
our office, and we
want to sneak in
a Facebook video,
closed captioning is helpful.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's awesome, those
are really great examples, and I
love how it's really connecting
this idea of designing
for the extremes,
and then it becomes more
usable for everyone.
ELISE ROY: Exactly, yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really great.
Elise, thank you so much
for joining us, and sharing
your gifts and your insights,
I really appreciate it.
ELISE ROY: Thank you
so much for having me.
I really appreciate it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]